Let's continue solving the system and see what happens. If I add the x terms
together I get 0, if I add the y terms together I also get 0, and then 6 and 5
make 11. Hm, this is weird, 0 equals 11. This can't be a true statement, we know
this isn't right. So something else is going on with these 2 equations. If we
remember that the solution to a system of equations is a point of intersection,
then we know that this doesn't make sense. There's actually no point that works
as the intersection for both of these 2 lines. If I solve each equation for y, I
would wind up with these 2 equations. These parallel lines will never intersect.
So whenever we connect this math to the graph, we can tell that there's no
solution here. There's no ordered pair, x and y, that will make both of these
equations true. And that makes sense, because there's no point of intersection.